this is a desolatory interview in
keeping with the theme of the
indeterminate and unfolding nature of
time for those who were intrigued by
louis el sando's comments on the blurred
notion of the present i.e his metaphor
of the cigarette that burns unevenly
nicholas jisson's concept of thick time
is the closest i've heard to a rigorous
account of it
nicholas jison is a professor at the
university of geneva working on the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
quantum information both experimentally
and theoretically in this episode we
talk about the existence of free will
the indeterminacy of reality and the
unreality of the real numbers nicholas
is one of the world renowned experts in
quantum theory and we're extremely
grateful that his first podcast
appearance is on the theories of
everything channel thank you professor
click on the time stamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channel's themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kerchamungle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliant for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su 2 cross su 3
those are league groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy i'm also interested
in the topic of free will that's why
you're here i was speaking with a
professor of
the of the philosophy of mathematics who
referenced me an article of yours quite
some time ago and ever since then i
thought okay i want to speak to this
person but i didn't have a reason to but
now i do so
thank you
so which paper is that do you remember i
don't remember you had the baker map and
you were showing that there is
indeterminacy with uh classical laws of
physics and you don't need quantum
mechanics to have that i don't recall
exactly okay so it's not valuable yeah
yeah i know i know which paper
from what i gathered i've been watching
plenty of your talks recently plenty and
plenty of them and even i went through
your book which is almost a decade old
now called quantum chance
which is a wonderful book
delightful book
most books about physics are or can be
intimidating to someone who's not
familiar with mathematics but this book
was so
winsome and childlike in its curiosity
instead of bells and equality of bell's
game
you give the reader the impression that
you're not speaking above them just
changing bells and equality to bell's
games it's a delightful conceptual shift
that makes it much more lucid for those
who are ordinarily intimidated by
mathematics
yeah you know the subject i find the
subject fascinating i mean that's i
spent my life on quantum physics quantum
chants and so on indeterminacy
and um i wanted to
to allow everyone to to
you know to share that
fascination um
so without mathematics indeed but also
without hiding the the conceptual
difficulties it's not trivial these
things it's a major change in our
worldview
so it is i wouldn't say it's an easy
book
but the goal was indeed to allow
everyone who is willing to make an
intellectual efforts to
to be able to to share some of this
fascination and gain some understanding
of why physicists are so excited about
bell
inequalities games and in determinism
and so on
even something as complicated sounding
as a quantum random number generator
which to many people they're like well
firstly what is random and then it
generates numbers and is quantum on top
of that well you explain it's just a
beam splitter and just think of it like
zeros and ones on each side
it's a splendid explanation of what's
customarily complicated
yeah and actually what is even very nice
here so you know there is all these
conceptual issues that you just
mentioned which are not trivial you can
make it relatively simple but not
completely trivial certainly not but it
goes all the way that now actually this
startup company from my
university group id queue
they may put everything into a little
chip which is just a few millimeter in
size
and um
it's also lower power consumption so
it's a it's a quantum render number
generator that actually is used by
samsung in some of their smartphones
have you done much thinking about the
nature of consciousness i know that
you've spoken about free will and time
and indeterminacy
consciousness no you know i'm a
physicist i'm not a philosopher so even
about free will
which is certainly uh something which i
think uh is a
an important concept but it's not a
concept of physics
so i you know unconsciousness
probably even less so i don't know if
it's less or but i mean there's a
certain number of concepts that are
completely outside of today's physics
whether they will ever be
within physics i don't know um
so maybe i should indeed warn you and
everyone uh listening to this that i'm
not a philosopher i don't claim to be a
philosopher
and i certainly claim that
consciousness free will the mind or
things like that
are fascinating concepts we all know
that we we have that
but these are not concepts that belong
to today's physics possibly not even
to future physics
from what i gathered from my research
into your views your philosophy
so to speak
you see free will and indeterminacy as
not tied now is this correct
why is it so yes
ordinary i'm sure you know the ordinary
view or not the ordinary i'm sure you
know the common view in philosophy and
even in physics some people who dabble
in philosophy who are physicists think
if you're going to have a notion of free
will it's predicated on indeterminacy
yeah so i certainly i'm certainly not a
compatibilist i don't really understand
how one could
claim that
you know the future is already given is
already determined by the present and
nevertheless we have free will i think
that's a more
a game of words so indeterminism is
necessary but in determinism is
certainly also not sufficient because
free will is also not just randomness we
don't want to make random
decisions
so it's much more complicated never
determinism you know pure indeterminism
is sufficient to explain free will this
sense again free will is not part of
today's physics
and i would probably
go even further and say that
you know so i'm now going to give some
uh
some arguments and so on
and everyone can then buy these
arguments or reject them but in order to
buy or reject these arguments you need
some free will
so somehow you need free will to start
arguing to start
doing philosophy or to start doing
physics
so
probably the best i can say about free
will is that is a prerequisite
uh in order to uh to
yeah to start arguing so in particular
for philosophy and science in general
when you say that free will is necessary
in order to choose between truths in
order for you to say this one is true
and not this one
then it sounds like you're tying free
will to reason is that the case
or to rationality
to rationality yes absolutely no it's
not a matter of being true or not true
you know i mean
you you may buy an argument or not and
you may even change your mind in course
of time
but
you need to be able to decide yeah now
this argument that i just
listened to
is convincing or no this is not
convincing enough
i'm not going to change my mind because
of that little argument so you need to
make decisions about what kind of
arguments you are going to buy and which
one you're going to reject
and so you need indeed this this ability
of
admitting or rejecting uh arguments
uh in order to to start arguing or to to
enter any debate and again philosophy
science and all that
i have a quote from you which says free
will comes first in the logical order
indeed without free will there's no way
to make sense of anything and in
particular there would be no
understanding
remember earlier in the conversation i
said i i'm interested in the notion of
time free will
consciousness is well i see them as
intimately tied and you mentioned well
forget about consciousness who knows
about that
however right there you said free will
is tied to understanding now penrose
makes a connection between understanding
and consciousness i don't know if you
know that argument maybe not exactly i
i've read so many things from penrose so
probably it's maybe in the back of my
mind but indeed i mean absolutely
correct i mean free will in my opinion
comes first in the logical order
and because of that you know physics or
science or psychology whatever
cannot argue against free will
because it rests on free will
yes then now let's explain that because
even to me as someone who's been looking
into this that i found that to be a new
notion i didn't encounter that before so
firstly how did you come to that
conclusion and then can you explain that
conclusion
how did i came to it i don't know i you
know of your own free will you came to
i
i was thinking about free will and
randomness and uh determinism and
passage of time
ever since i was a teenager
and so i don't there's not really one
point in time when suddenly aha now it
was so it's really something that
evolved
and at some point i was invited to a
conference to deliver a talk of course
and the conference was actually about
time and i was a bit surprised to be
invited but okay i thought this is
really a good chance and so i
i went to it and i i had of course to
prepare myself and that's actually when
i started really formulating these ideas
a bit more
in a more articulated way like you know
stating that free will comes first in
the logical order
there is no understanding without free
will and so on
but then also when i
uh
during
i think it was during that conference
some colleagues
mentioned in particular chris fox
mentioned to me
um
that there's an old
unknown essentially a french philosopher
le quiere
who actually had very similar thoughts
he was
the queer was also very much influenced
much more from myself certainly by
religious beliefs so god was his problem
how could god know everything and me
still having free will
that's the old version is it
appreciative version of the free will
debate
um and like we came to the similar
conclusion as myself but of course
centuries before
saying that actually free will comes
first
and without free will we cannot even
start this kind of argument about god
having a
yeah full power
and uh
and so on or full knowledge
um
[Music]
yeah so so i noticed that i was not the
first and i thought that was kind of a
nice discovery for me
that this kind of idea were
uh not entirely new
but clearly also not very well known
now let's explain
what it means that free will comes first
in the logical order
if you start an argument
and don't have any free will
whether it is whether this argument is
going to resonate
is a purely let's say mechanical
stuff you know if i
hit my table here whether the table is
going to resonate
is just a matter of the mechanics of the
resonant frequencies of this table and
so on and how i hit it and so on
but for an argument to resonate
uh
in me
it's i think not just a matter of uh
i don't know it's not a mechanical
question
some arguments are convincing some of us
are not convincing and again that may
change in the course of time you don't
need to always be convinced by the same
argument during all your life span
so there must be something more and this
something more is actually what we name
free will this table has no free will it
doesn't decide to resonate to my hitting
it
while
you and me and everybody listening here
and so on
they may find points and now my argument
uh
uh
in that it resonates to
to them
or that they are willing to buy it or at
least to consider it or on the country
they will just reject it but whatever
they do it's like it's a free decision
it's something that depends on them it's
i don't think it is just a mechanical
consequence
of
you know of their bodies and their brain
and so on
so the way that i understand it is if i
was to make a bridge resonate i throw
wind at it and then it wobbles and
that's a physical process now if i throw
an idea at you or you to me if it
resonates with me we haven't we use the
same word resonate but we just mean well
we use the same word resonate that is
dependent not on the physics but on free
will
exactly i think that's that's exactly
yeah i think that that's correct of
course i know that some people will say
no no this is a purely a physical
phenomenon we don't i mean we first of
all don't exist it's everything is just
pure physics
but i think
going that far
first assumes that physics really
explains everything
it all almost assumes in between the
line that today's physics is close to an
end
which i consider ridiculous
and
yeah and and i think it uh
it bypasses
the beauty of life the beauty of uh
human beings including animals
of livings living beings what do your
colleagues say to you when you say
well perhaps physics doesn't explain
everything
the reductionist account including our
actions it goes from our actions to our
neurobiology to the chemistry to the
physics
and that's it physics that's it
yeah
again here um
depends where we're talking about
today's physics or even near future
physics of physics in general so science
is not at the end and will continue to
develop and there will be new ideas and
completely new things which will be
totally surprising to today's physicist
like quantum mechanics and relativity
are completely
foreign to uh 19th century physics
so there will be more revolutions
and um
so maybe there's one thing which seems
pretty clear is that today's physics
doesn't explain free will consciousness
or things like that
could it be that
future physics explain it certainly not
near future now what is really the very
far future of physics or science more
generally of course i don't know
but my
claim is that free will being
first in the logical order
physics or science more generally and
philosophy will never be able to fully
explain freewheel of course we can
explain part of it for instance today we
understand much better i find in the
19th century
the difference between hardware and
software
and this distinction
which is very common today but this is a
useful distinction to to start even to
think about you know the brain as just
being the material part and maybe some
software whatever that exactly means
and things like that but at least we can
start articulating ideas
uh thanks to
this distinction between software and
hardware that were completely
unthinkable
uh 200 years ago 150 years ago
so we can also expect that in the future
there will be new uh concepts
uh that's that we master or that
the future scientists will master
and that will help
uh better articulating the problem of
free will and consciousness and so on
but i don't think we will ever come to
an end in that if we will somehow some
essence of free will
will always remain
outside the scope of of science
and now yeah you also asked about my
colleagues
my colleagues
there many colleagues and i would say
the vast majority of the physicists
just don't care they are not going to
listen at all we just don't care
now among those that care
you know
they care after a few years
usually
uh and
most of them which then i don't know
i would they would listen to what i have
to say they would not necessarily agree
okay some have very strong opinions they
are strongly compatibilist but they
really thought about it that's okay
[Music]
and i guess we also quite a lot and i
have already experienced quite a lot of
my colleagues who are happy with what
i'm saying
but you know the happy is a small
minority
seriously unhappy is also a small small
minority and the enormous majority just
doesn't care
and why do you think the majority
doesn't care
it's too ill-defined they'll say
yeah it's too ill-defined it's
i don't exactly know how how they can
not
care about such important and deep
questions
maybe we just think that uh you know
they have not been trained in that so
they don't feel uh
competent
in this in this respect somehow
probably also if some of my colleagues i
tell them about some
subtleties in biology they may also just
say oh i i don't understand it it's
outside my field of competence actually
nowadays we get so specialized that you
don't even need to change feel and go
outside of physics
for not understanding what the colleague
is saying um
and uh maybe it is uh
it is uh
yeah it's a way of protecting yourself
just to say no notice i don't want to
touch it's outside my little field
of competence
do you think what governs free will is
mathematics or you think it's something
completely different
and this goes back to our reductionist
account okay yeah mathematics we we
should talk about mathematics and uh
and determinism
um but um
no i think
mathematics again and especially today's
mathematics has very very little to say
on
probably nothing to say on free will and
uh
and consciousness
the reason i say that is that when one
says well it's first in the logical
order the way i'm thinking is of the
traditional reductionist view and you go
down and down until you get to physics
and then sometimes people encapsulate
physics into math and then if free will
is first well then free will is prior to
math is that the correct way of looking
at it as these nested sets or is that
different i shouldn't be thinking about
it like that
i don't think you should be thinking of
nested
stats mathematics is
i guess it's really a kind of different
branch of
of science and of understanding
and again mathematics
in french we say
the mathematics it's really a plural
and indeed there are different
sources of mathematics you can really
think of mathematics as kind of
you know this purely platonistic view
where there are these mathematical
objects existing
you know outside of time outside of the
physical world
they just have their own existence with
their own rules
um
now again okay i'm probably not
prepared to really argue these rules
you know they depend on the axioms
in principle but okay yeah quite a lot
of
basic things like you know the integers
for instance the integer five
does it exist by itself in this
platonistic world i guess that's the
view that most mathematicians would
approach
but there are there are different sorts
of mathematics you have also mathematics
where people were more thinking
in terms of
that the mathematical objects would
themselves be
processes that develop and evolve in
time
uh okay the best example here is uh
intuitionistic mathematics that was
mostly uh
developed by brower
a hundred years ago about about 100
years ago
there are still today some people
developing this form of mathematics that
come under the general umbrella of
constructivists
but in this specific form of
constructivism called intuitionism
you really have that already at the
mathematical level
even numbers like okay what we call real
numbers are really evolving in time
and then if mathematics includes that
kind of and in unneeds the concept or
introduces the concept of time already
even at the level of numbers
then that makes this sort of mathematics
much closer
and possibly better suited
for for physics for science in general
so when you see mathematics it's not
clear what you mean
many of the people watching don't know
what constructivism what is a
constructionist
because it's not constructivism isn't it
constructivist well definite that i know
there's social constructivism in the
social construction i don't want to mix
that up
well i know intuitionism and i've always
seen intuitionism as the same as
the constructionist view in mathematics
but you just said that intuitionist is a
specific subset of constructionist what
would be an example of a constructionist
that is not an intuitionist
so constructivist just means that every
object one should be able to construct
them now it depends do you want to be
able to construct them now
and period is done
or
is it enough to have a rule that tells
you how the process of constructing
these these objects
develops in time
so somehow they are never finished there
are at least some of these processes
that we never finished
so they evolved in time and that's then
intuitionism
so intuitionism the intuition is that
things can evolve in time admittedly
brower when he developed that he was
thinking about you know you may define a
number
uh
depending on some mathematical
conjecture
and depending how this conjecture will
turn out you know true or false the
number may be you know zero one let's
say and so the number is undefined until
this conjecture this specific conjecture
is solved but that brings now
mathematics or this form of
intuitionistic mathematics very much to
what humans are able to do
prove or not prove this uh
conjecture
while my understanding and other
people's understanding of intuition is
just that
as time passes new information gets
created continuously
and hence
a number may evolve according to this
new information
so the standard view in mathematics is
classical mathematics and that is to say
that we're discovering it and it's
timeless so the pythagorean theorem is
timeless we just found it and it existed
before humans now brower would say well
it didn't exist until we discovered it
and then brower was a type of
intuitionist but that's a bit too
anthropocentric so we say now well
there's still intuitionism it's just
that the universe itself reveals new
information
exactly
it is correct but of course about the
petagon
theorem once it is on the table
there's nothing more to to add on that
but you can imagine that just a number
that sounds let's say zero dot and then
you have all the digits that come
afterwards
um
and some of these far away uh digits may
not yet be determined
but those new information gets created
these uh far down the series uh digits
may get
determined
you should know that the audience for
this is generally upper year
undergrads
so in math and physics so for them can
you explain
how
indeterminacy arises in classical
physics
like a few arguments and you can also
outline your views on the real numbers
aren't real and so on because those are
tight
yeah yeah it's it's it's all connected
indeed
so very important uh
to understand first is
chaos in classical mechanics you have
okay newton's law and all that and you
may use hamiltonian's equation whatever
the equation that you you learn at
school and university
um and usually one then gives us some
examples and the examples will be a
harmonic oscillator you know just a kind
of pendulum that oscillates very
regularly or you may have a
i don't know
a star or a planet orbiting its star
like earth orbiting the sun which again
is a very very regular motion
but actually when you look at all the
possible configurations of these uh
mata particles you notice that
almost all actually with probability one
the system that you're going to consider
actually
is not regular
but it's chaotic and by chaotic it means
that's the
[Music]
the future
of this
set of particles
depends
super sensitively on the initial
condition so you take an initial
condition which is usually defined by a
real number and now you change the
digits number one thousand or one
million whatever
and of course initially you don't see
any difference if you let these systems
evolve
but if the system is chaotic pretty
quickly the system will evolve
completely differently although you have
only changed the digits
1000
positions down there the string of
digits
and then comes the question is that
still a deterministic system or not
so first of all obviously it is not
deterministic in the sense that you
cannot control all these digits it's
it's beyond our technology but still you
can now go more on the ontology side
does this
1 000 or 1 million
digits really exist
since ever
and hence
this chaotic system actually evolved in
a fully deterministic way we don't know
which way but it is deterministic
or is it the case that this
billion for millionth digit actually is
undetermined
at time t0 and hence the evolution of
this chaotic system
will be also undetermined as time passes
this digit will get
determined
gain a determined value but initially at
time t zero it has no determined value
and if you think like that
so if you replace classical mathematics
by intuitionistic mathematics
you make the same predictions
statistical predictions anyway
but very importantly with intuitionistic
mathematics you see that
a chaotic classical system is no longer
deterministic it becomes indeterministic
although it is classical physics still
although the equations are still
newton's equations and all that
and so indeed i i like to argue that is
uh
first of all that it already shows that
just by changing the mathematics
contrary to what we learned they are
more fun one mathematics
and if you go to another form of
mathematics you don't change the
prediction since all the empirical
you know confirmation of physics remains
but
instead of presenting you with a
deterministic worldview the same theory
newton's theory in this case classical
mechanics presents you with an
indeterministic worldview
so you see it's really you can choose
you can use your free will to choose
whether you prefer one or the other but
it's not
the facts that are going to choose for
you
and then there's one more argument which
i'd like to put on the table
you know a real number a typical real
number you know this integer dot and
then all these digits
that contains actually an infinite
amount of information because this
series of digits
they typically contain no structure at
all it's not like one third one third
it's zero dot and then you have only
three free free that just repeats itself
but a typical real number will have no
structure at all and that means that if
you want to describe it you have to give
everything every every digit but there
are infinitely many digits so that's
infinitely many uh it's an infinite
amount of information
i know if you think that's
you know you you make the assumption
that in a finite volume of space
you have only a finite
amount of information you cannot pack
infinite information into a finite
volume
then the natural consequence of this
assumption
is that if you have now
be a ball or anything in your
small volume finite volume
the center of mass of that or any other
degree of freedom cannot be faithfully
described by a real number because if it
would be a real number you would have to
pack all this
infinite information into your finite
volume
and so from that i uh yeah i concluded
and i have a paper with this uh nice
title
real numbers are not really real
you know these real numbers we've got
cold wheel by day cat for easter
historical reasons
and we still use this terminology of
real numbers
but if you look at them from a physics
point of view they're not really real
usually people who say that the real
numbers aren't real are a fan of digital
physics that this computation underneath
in the laws of physics or computation
okay so stephen wolfram for example do
you subscribe to this
not entirely i guess in part yes
but what i add to that but i think it's
important to add is really this idea
that these
these numbers are evolving in time so
you still have for instance the
continuum uh voltron would not have the
continuum in this sense but with uh
intuitionistic mathematics you have
these numbers evolve and so this digit
which is initially undetermined
will get determined in proper time
and uh and so the
yeah first of all
if this digit becomes very important
let's say in a week time because it
would determine the weather in a week
um it cannot be that the weather in a
time
in one week from now the weather will be
you know determined it will be sunny or
rainy or in between but it will be
something
so at some point in time these chaotic
systems
they must
settle down they must get determined
it's not enough to have some granule
granularity in it you need that they
settle and in this sense i think that
intuitionistic mathematics is a is an
appropriate
language mathematical language
to describe this idea that although
things may not be determined today the
weather in a weak time from today
is not yet determined but it will be
determined in a weak time
now how do you get from this
intuitionist view to the view that time
is thick
that you can't pull out a single point
of time there's much like molasses
yeah yeah um
okay this the argument here is
if you have let's see imagine two
processes or two numbers
that initially are exactly the same
but they evolve in time and maybe after
some time they may split
you know this new information that gets
created as time passes may be
different
and so
these two numbers
now or even in the near future we can
just not distinguish them because so far
they are exactly the same
but they may become different
and so somehow
you know
these numbers they are they stick
together be a bit like yeah yeah this is
that you cannot really uh
you know or honey you cannot really take
out a
molecule of honey they stick together
and these numbers also kind of stick
together and
that's uh that's where the the intuition
of this fake time in intuitionistic
mathematics
comes from
uh but i i'm not really uh
okay i don't claim that i have a
a full understanding of uh
of time in in nutritionistic mathematics
let's say can you give an example more
simply so let's say the number 2.00
let's imagine that we only know up to
three significant digits are you saying
that if there's a couple phenomenon that
has 2.00 as the
numerical value of them
and maybe it's position maybe another
one's charged i don't it doesn't matter
if i'm looking at them right now i say
they're the same they're both 2.00 but
later they may diverge and maybe 2.001
for this one 2.005 for this one yes how
does that have to do with being thick or
being like honey i don't see the
connection there
well it means that
at any time
now for instance you cannot distinguish
them
so they still stick together
although they are different in the sense
that as you said i mean in a in a second
or maybe in a day
it will be 2.001 for one of them and
2.005 for the hour so they clearly are
different
but nevertheless today they stick
together
ah ah okay so time gets increasingly
more specific
i mean sorry
is it it's not well i don't think i said
that correctly so correct what i said i
said time gets increasingly more
specific but it's more like the
quantities that we're measuring it or
the quantities that exist get more
specific
exactly the quantities that exist get
more specific or i would use the
terminology they get more determined i'm
trying to understand how is it that the
present is thick so you're saying the
present is thick because it then
fractionates later and that means that
any moment in the future is actually
less thick than a moment in the past
no i don't think so because it can
happen again in the future even once
it's 2.001 let's say it's settled for
2.001
but you still have the fit the same kind
of thickness for the next digit uh so
the all is obvious
it evolves forever
okay and they're all equally as thick
because they're all just indeterminate
at the last digit
whether the time is t 010 okay yeah if
you want to be more precise it's not a
matter of the digit it's really
additional information
but never mind the intuition is good
with these digits yes
many younger people especially don't
know about intuitionist mathematics they
don't even know that there's a
difference in mathematics they just
think it's classical mathematics so i'm
going to outline some of how and i'm
going to place a slide of yours up on
the screen how indeterministic physics
and intuitionist mathematics map on to
one another yeah probably yes yes yes
and there's a paper in the philosophy
journal syntase that appeared i think
last summer i think which is indeed
indeterministic physics and
intuitionistic mathematics something
like that is the title
so maybe you can just give a give a link
to that it's not a difficult paper okay
great i'll give a link to that now the
future is open in indeterministic
physics that gets analogized or mapped
onto or made equivalent with the law of
the excluded middle not being there okay
so firstly can you explain what the law
of the excluded middle is and then why
the heck that means that the future is
open
yeah so this law of the excluded middle
says so it's a part of let's say
classical logic classical mathematics
that says that every statement every
proposition
is ever true or false
so it cannot be something else it's even
true or false so if i'm not saying
uh it will be raining in exactly a year
time
in geneva in my guard let's say
this statement according to classical
logic has to be ever true and then for
sure it will rain or it is false and
then for sure it will not rain of course
i may be ignorant about whether it is
true or false for sure i mean don't talk
about about that
but the fact is that this proposition
has a true value consequently the future
because my statement my proposition here
is about the future
but if now this proposition has a true
value it means that this future
somehow already exists or at least is
already determined
that's determinism
now if i want to have a
a different view
saying that this weather in a year time
not only do i not know whether it will
be uh sony or any but it is truly
undetermined
it's not yet settled whether it will be
one way or the other
um
and then it means that a proposition
about this future whether
is never true nor false
it takes a third value and this third
value is just in determined
indeterminate indeterminate
so we have now a new sort of
of logic
which is no longer with two values it
has this third value but the third value
is not
50
50
or grey it just says
it is indeterminate
and this is certainly part of
intuitionistic mathematics
but you know i think it's also part of
everyone's okay everyone probably not
but most people intuition if i tell you
something about what happens in a year
time in a football match or about the
weather or
a volcano or whatever
well it is us of today indeterminate
you made me think of some personal
questions so this young nicholas when
you're sitting in philosophizing about
the nature of time and indeterminacy and
free will etc
and you meddled you meddled with
mathematics at the logical level so
there's different types of logic
mathematics is based on logic classical
logic and intuitionist logic did you
meddle so far
outside of intuitionist
logic such as grand priests pair
consistent logic or other forms of logic
or have you settled on intuitionists and
why
well so actually the the situation is
following i was
um okay thinking about that and indeed
the young nicola i was already thinking
about what's randomness now i i think
it's a super complicated concept
um
and
i don't remember now let's say five
years ago i was writing a paper
that appeared in another philosophy
journalist that's the that's the paper
which has the subtitle real numbers are
not really real
um and
okay and so then at some point i
presented that at the conference
and one of the the participants
cal posse who is actually a
professor of philosophy and logic in
jerusalem
mentioned to me this intuitionistic
mathematics so i didn't know
intuitionistic mathematics but clearly
what i was
adds with my my real numbers are not
really real i was somehow rediscovering
intuitionistic mathematics
trying to reinvent it of course i didn't
went as far as all these people doing
that it's an entire community
but so then thanks to to cal posse i
learned about it and he also
told me about it and it's not difficult
to understand because it's really just
corresponds quite closely to my
intuition about how things are going
and so i understood it and then i wrote
this over paper the syntase one
about indeterminist
indeterminism in physics and
intuitionistic mathematics
to show really how these two
connect to each other very nicely
but maybe i can come back to this real
number because i think many people many
of my colleagues have similar intuition
you know we all think we all many of us
think you know a real number you get all
these digits and then you know we can
think of the other digits they come one
after the other
and they come one after the other
in time you know one is he and then he
comes the next then comes the next then
comes the next
but actually proper classical
mathematics says something very
different proper classical mathematics
claims that a real number is this
infinite
series of numbers of digits this
infinite amount of information
comes all at once in zero time
so when you say let x 0 be the initial
condition
and x 0 you assume it's a real number or
even a bunch of real numbers if you have
many degrees of freedom it actually
means let there be
instantaneously buff
infinite information
and that's an enormous assumption and i
don't think most physicists really think
that way they really think okay there is
this number and there are some digits
and then
well who cares anyway but these numbers
these digits sorry they come really
one after the other and now we say one
after the other in time
and then you have intuitionistic
mathematics
part of the reason why many physicists
don't have much of a trouble with real
numbers is that i don't think they think
in terms of a billiard ball carrying its
position with it if it carried it like
on a piece of paper on a sticky note
metaphorically it would create a black
hole instantly typically unless it's
because the typical real number has
infinite okay so then the way they
you've explained it to me is that
you imagine it like the
electron or the billiard ball does carry
with its position that's that still a
metaphor or is that meant to be
taken more literally
if it's just the the center of mass of
course then it depends on the reference
frame anyway but you could imagine the
the
kinetic momentum
or you could also imagine just you have
a molecule or you have a little system
with morph and one particle and then the
relative
degrees of freedom you know the distance
between
a planet and its sun
this is really within the system
the system being the global thing
and then you can really think i mean
then it makes sense to to
to think that
these these relative degrees of freedom
are really represented by numbers
carrots by the system it's really
internal of it now you may say okay it
depends if i'm measuring that with uh
miles or kilometers or whatever
but that is indeed where
if we think in terms of the amount of
information it's the same
now if i really think in terms of the
digit of course if i change my units the
digits will change but the amount of
information will in both cases be
infinite
okay now getting to the reality of time
again the commonplace view in physics is
that arrow of time is an illusion in
fact time itself may be an illusion like
carla rivelli suggests because the laws
of nature as far as we have are
symmetric except for the second do you
see the second law as being what
engenders the
error of time or you see it as being so
much more fundamental
it's more fundamental it comes already
in the basic mathematics
in the basic mathematics we don't erase
information we create information as
time passes so the direction of time is
already built into the into our
mathematical language
and i think again that comes much closer
to the intuition that everyone has of
course if you learn too much of
classical mechanics or quantum mechanics
with the schrodinger equation
you may get
the feeling that because the equation
are time reversal
then time is an illusion
but that's because you use classical
mathematics to
describe
um
to uh
initial condition for this for this
equation for these evolution equations
now if you just use this different form
of mathematics
then even if the equation has still the
symmetry the initial condition no longer
has that symmetry
something i'm extremely excited about
exploring on this channel are different
approaches to quantum gravity and you
said in an offhand statement is that i
think we need a different understanding
of time in order to make a breakthrough
in quantum gravity please explain that
yes yes
yeah so indeed so quantum gravity that's
of course a huge challenge and uh
very little progress in the in the last
uh decades
uh okay maybe i'm going to annoy a few
of my colleagues but i don't think we
have made any breakthrough i think
that's a fair statement to be fair
professor almost everyone has a
variation of that statement that we need
a new understanding of x in order to
make progress in quantum gravity whether
we need a new understanding of space we
need a new understanding of strings we
need a new understanding of holographic
so why time
okay okay good so why time
so time has plays a completely different
role in relativity so gravity and in
quantum mechanics uh you know in
relativity i mean that the usual picture
is this block universe where everything
is kind of frozen
since ever forever and there is no no
present or you have to add it by hand
and even einstein was a bit uh concerned
with the lack of the present
uh in quantum mechanics at least
the standard view is this indeterminacy
on the beam splitter with the two
detectors for instance
and so there there is clearly a process
going on nowadays
before the photon hits the detector and
gets localized in one or the other
detector
and there is a time after it has
triggered one and only one of the
detectors so there is clearly a passage
of time there
and now we have this uh
these two uh
basic theories
which
they fundamentally disagree about what
time is
and then how do you want you know to
develop
dynamical theory of quantum gravity
if we don't even agree on what time is
and whether this is you know whether the
passage of time is a real phenomenon us
in standard
quantum mechanics
or is it
just a kind of illusion us in the block
universe presented by relativity
so i think this is really a
fundamental issue and we need to be able
to
[Music]
yeah
if we want to do quantum gravity we need
to have one concept that is going to
unify that
i know i wouldn't say that i have solved
the problem i mean certainly not
but i uh my hope is that by you know
introducing indetermination also in
classical
pre-relativity mechanics
so newtonian mechanics but i have
already introduced uh indetermination
there so somehow i have brought at least
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics closer together
i have also one paper on the
indeterminacy is relative so going one
more step in the direction of relativity
but okay this is maybe it's uh
i don't think we should enter that kind
of debate anyway it is still under
development but the goal is indeed to
bring also indetermination to uh
relativity
professor whenever you speak i have so
many questions that are there's so many
that come to my mind okay so first do
you have an idea as to the
discretization of space and time do you
think it's discrete okay
let me just be fair i don't know
the way i describe time in this uh
well like all the others in
intuitionistic mathematics it is
discrete is it fundamentally discrete is
it a technical problem today i don't
know
also you mentioned that
you were similar to that philosopher
which i forgot the name of i know
william james was influenced by someone
who published that person's work because
that person died young oh yeah so so the
okay the guy i mentioned before is le
quiere
uh
jacques le cui i think
and then there was indeed a person in
between le quiere and uh william james
and that's
i think also a french philosopher
the first one i'm not going to even try
to pronounce now that person le quiere
that's how i tried to pronounce it le
quiere
was
spurred by a religious instinct or these
religious questions you mentioned you
feel similar to him
so i'm curious about your religious
views
oh well
okay in some sense i'm certainly not a
religious person so i never go to church
or things like that
my children are not baptized and so on
um
but you know the fact that i spend time
thinking about free will
consciousness
time
you know it's really taking physics
a stretch maybe physics a bit beyond the
standard physics to to go in the
direction of philosophy and i mentioned
already two of my papers in philosophy
journals actually i have very little
publications in philosophy journals i
think i have four of them if i remember
well so it's very few compared to the
numbers of papers i have in physics so
i'm mostly really a physicist but i'm a
physicist with a kind of yeah i like
kind of broad view
and by that i mean that these questions
are important to me
now you may say
okay is that a religious
feeling or something like that i'm
certainly not following any uh you know
book uh
religious book or things now
no
okay let's talk about sabine haasenfeld
who says that the idea of free will is
both incompatible with the laws of
nature and entirely meaningless okay
what are your thoughts on that statement
yeah so i i know sabine
and i use actually so so she does a lot
of these videos
and i love most of them
now she has one indeed on freewheel and
actually i use that one when i give some
of my lectures
uh to um to illustrate how extreme some
physicists
including very good physicists
can become and indeed in this video
sabine goes really a very long way and
you know claiming that if you believe in
free will you are denying signs
so she is really claiming that actually
science has answered the question in the
negative there is no free will
and this is in my opinion a clear
overstatement it's it's taking physics
as a religion somehow
and it's physics with classical
mathematics again we just discussed that
[Music]
and it's pretty strange that uh sabine
often felder makes that kind of mistake
because one of
her book
which i like very much i think it's
called lost in mathematics
actually
um yeah says we have to be careful we
the physicist have to be careful not to
overestimate
mathematics
you know in high energy physics
people try to uh
to guess the future theories just by the
beauty of mathematics by symmetries and
elegance and things like that
and um
[Music]
so she says no but maybe actually the
the the correct mathematics of the next
uh
physics uh theory will not be as elegant
as we
think or would like it to be
so okay that's a reasonable argument and
i certainly buy that argument but then
herself
takes classical platonistic mathematics
the truth
and because platonistic mathematics
considers only
objects mathematical objects that are
outside of time
it's a timeless language classical
mathematics and so when she concludes
that time cannot exist and that
everything has already to be settled so
she also believes strongly
in super determinism
you know everything is already
determined there is no quantum
randomness
bill inequality violations can be
explained by
super determinism
and yeah at least she's very consistent
that uh certainly grant her
but when when she claims that science
has proved it for instance
that free will is an illusion
uh she goes too far
and she goes too far by taking
mathematics too uh literally
can you quickly outline to the audience
what super determinism is perhaps what
you dislike about it
yeah well actually there are two things
that i dislike so firstly there's
already determinism let me come back to
that but so you know the entire future
like the entire past everything is
already determined doesn't mean that we
know it or it doesn't even mean that we
have any ability to
get that knowledge
but you know
ontologically fundamentally it is
already
that's determinism now when people say
super determinism they add an extra
little assumption
namely that
um okay it's that everything is
coordinated because you could still
imagine that you know this part of the
universe is entirely determined
that part is also entirely determined
but they are not yet connected so we are
still independent systems that exist in
the world now if you i if you also
reject the existence of in
independent systems
then this is
super determinism some other people
would probably
say that super the super of super
determinism means
a kind of conspiracy because when these
these different things not only needs to
be already
connected so not
independent but they have to be not
independent in a very specific way for
instance to explain the violation or the
apparent violation of bell inequality so
i certainly dislike completely the idea
that there exists no
systems in the universe
and actually my my view is
very clearly i mean physics has to be
able to tell stories physics should make
predictions we all know that and
predictions of course should agree with
the experiments
but physics is not only about
[Music]
sophisticated theories physics is also
about telling a story
you know when you go to a class or if
you teach us i did a lot
you never start by writing an equation
you start by telling a story
and for instance everyone knows
most people know that the tides are due
to the moon that attracts the water from
the ocean and so on and so on and you
don't need an equation for that story so
the stories are super important
in science in general and also in in
physics
but there are no stories without
time
you need to be telling something in time
an event takes place in time that the
moon attracts this water is something
that takes place in time if you remove
the time
there is no story any longer
um and how does time come in
for me time is very very much connected
to the actualization of uh
potentialities as aristotle would have
said you know to the fact that this new
information created
during the the course of time
uh so it has to do with indeterminism
and now so that already explains you why
i think if
we've just deterministic stories
i don't think we can really tell how
nature does it earlier in the
conversation you said indeterminacy is
the necessary condition for free will
it's not sufficient
however any indeterminate theory can be
made determinate with supplementary
variables we can talk about that just
for people who are wondering what the
heck that means and then similarly a
determinate theory can be made
indeterminate so they're equivalent
and thus is determinancy truly a
necessary condition for free will
yeah well the way to make an
indeterministic theory deterministic is
by adding
adding variables
and the trivial way of adding variables
is just to add all the future results of
all future events or future measurements
it's a trivial way of doing it it's not
very practical it's not very useful but
obviously you can always do that somehow
maybe one could say that instead of god
playing dice when
an event happen
god played all dies at the initial
condition at the big bang
and
coded all this
information of all these guys that he
played initially he coded it into the
initial conditions the initial
conditions of you know these real
numbers that contain all this
information of all future events
or in bohmian quantum mechanics it's a
similar idea you have these additional
variables that also contain infinite
information and that somehow in a clever
way code all the outcomes of all
possible future measurements
so you can always do that
but you don't want
just to be able to do it you want to be
able to do it in a faithful way you want
to describe nature in a faithful way
and adding the result of future
measurements
uh into your initial condition i don't
think this is uh
this is a faithful description when i
was speaking with carla rivelli he said
there are two interpretations of quantum
mechanics that he feels like are
consistent relational quantum mechanics
and then the many worlds
right of course but he doesn't like the
many world's interpretation so he
chooses the relational one
now from my understanding of your views
there can't be a wave function of the
universe because this can't just simply
evolve in time determinately is that an
incorrect reading
correct correct
okay now does that mean that you don't
believe in the many worlds
interpretation
no not not at all i think that's quite a
an empty concept and i think the
explanatory power of many worlds is
essentially zero
uh again it's it's again one of these
things which is super deterministic you
know that is the initial wave function
of the universe and then everything
evolves according to that and there is
never any event that happens nothing
really happens it just is this unitary
evolution which is an enormous uh
rotation in this gigantic hilbert space
uh so that's something that there's
nothing happening there you cannot tell
a story here
um no no so my view and much closer i'm
not claiming that i have the solution to
all these problems but my
my feeling is much closer my heart is
much closer to a
spontaneous localization theory so
stochastic evolution of the the
schrodinger equation
and so in this way also the you know as
time passes this uh
schrodinger equation of this wave
function sorry gets i added
additional information a bit like my
numbers for classical mechanics and as
time passes this additional information
that gets added to the to the wave
function may localize it here or there
with appropriate probabilities and we
are stochastic equations doing that
perfectly i won't keep you for much
longer i know that you probably have to
get going soon so i'll just ask a couple
more questions now going back to when
you were younger and your little
nicholas was philosophizing in his
armchair and you dabbled with different
logical systems so we talked about
paraconsistence and intuitionist did you
dabble with questioning even if logic
should be the basis of mathematics
itself
um well when i did my phd in geneva
indeed a long time ago
my
phd advisor professor piron
was actually a guy working in in quantum
logic i don't think himself really
believes in quantum logic but there are
many people around and so we had
visitors
who were really uh
thinking of this quantum logic and that
by changing that the laws of logic we
could make sense of better sense of
quantum mechanics
i i don't think that this is an
interesting approach
um
i i think that that's
okay no so my answer to your question is
no
and again this is uh
so i'm i'm rejecting the law of the
excluded middle
essentially
about propositions that concern the
future
you know my bicycle now you may ask is
my bicycle on that side or on that side
well maybe i forgot actually i know but
suppose i forgot
even if i forgot why my bicycle is my
bicycle is definitely either there or
there it's not in an indeterminate
position
now if you ask me where will my bicycle
be in a weak time
that's indeterminate also today
one of my favorite ways of showing that
classical mechanics has indeterminacy
built in it is norton's dome have you
heard of norton's dome
yes yes i know that
yeah well but this is uh
okay it's a very nice example that that
shows that indeed you may have
initial conditions
that don't determine the the future of
these dynamical systems but you need
very specific dynamical systems now you
need this dome that's why it's called a
dome in such a way that if you have a
particle coming to that dome it will
okay if you don't through it hard enough
it will just go up and back again if you
throw it too far
it goes over it and goes to the other
side so there's precisely an initial
condition initial velocity such that it
will stop at the top
and that doesn't exist for all domes it
exists only for
very specific domes and for this very
specific dome so of course whether or
not the ball comes from that side or
from any side let's suppose it's a two
dimensional thing
but from any direction it can stop at
the top
which means now the initial condition it
may go at any time in any direction and
that will always be a solution of the
newton's equation
but so this is fascinating indeed but i
don't think it's super convincing
because
you know if you change
the
the shape of that dome by an epsilon by
a little bit
it's gone i mean this uh this
peculiarity is gone
so you it it is not a generic feature
it's a feature of some very very
specific dome or potential as we call it
the reason why i like it is because i
know that it's predicated on real
numbers and so on so maybe that's
another dispute you have with it the
reason why i like it is that even in the
classical domain we can show that it
doesn't have certain continuity
condition and then because of that it
allows for multiple solutions and not
only that but you mentioned that it's
not a generic feature i don't know if
there's a result that says much like we
can say that the typical real number has
infinite information in it i don't know
if there's a result that says the
typical configuration of matter is that
which has a lipschitz continuity
condition i would think it's the
opposite i would think that
not satisfying the lipschitz continuity
condition would be typical if we have
the general space of functions
i don't know if that's true i don't know
if there's a result like that
okay um i also don't know
my bet is that this is very uh very
specific and generically we don't have
this phenomenon but i cannot
i'm not sure about that
my last question is with regard to
quantum gravity is there an approach
that you favor
make relativity deterministic
but you know
that's a vast program
[Music]
okay now let's get to the audience
questions this one comes from steven e
robbins a great question to ask nicholas
is i'm curious if
he has looked at bergson time and free
will
wait yes i'm curious if he's looked at
burksen so that's it
yeah yeah so i i looked at it i read
some of it i mean it's too too large i
didn't read everything
uh certainly a lot of his writing
resonates
um
but somehow
that's where i'm i'm
a physicist much more fun and
philosopher and the excellent was
clearly a philosopher so at some point
it is kind of too vague i cannot really
you know
grasp it i cannot really anchor
on it and uh
and
yeah so for that reason uh i i
i think i cite him even in one of my
paper things like that so
i i'm certainly sympathetic
but um
it's not really my way of doing physics
or science
now this question comes from complex
plane at
k-e-k-u-l-e-6 does he think that the
denial of free will by physicists is an
attempt to make evidence fit a model now
chomsky says that it may be something
outside human cognitive abilities that
is free will to understand
does he hold a similar view
i i don't really know again i mean for
me free will comes first
in this logical order so you need it to
start
arguing about the existence of free will
so somehow you cannot really deny the
existence of free will because if you
want to to argue against the existence
of free will you need free will to be
able to buy or not buy the argument
then someone may say well how is it that
you're choosing so and so because we use
our free will to choose among
possibilities are you saying there's
nothing that influences that is it
random how does that work no no no no so
of course we get influenced i mean
obviously we are under very heavy
influence and so so free will is not
something that we use continuously and
so on i mean most of our even decisions
are not so important and so on
and we get influenced by ads and
whatever
um
and they're also not random i mean they
might be partially random
you can for instance decide and whether
you go to a restaurant tonight or by
just tossing a coin
um so sometimes it will be but most of
the time it will be not random
and not predetermined
now you may say but who is now making
the decision is there a little guy in my
brain
well it should be myself so i i'm not
sitting in my brain or whatever so
that's where
[Music]
our understanding of what free will is
uh is limited we don't have this kind of
uh understanding
and maybe that comes also back to what
you asked initially about consciousness
somehow
am i i'm making conscious decisions not
always by the way but sometimes i'm
making conscious decisions
and um
[Music]
yeah
i i
[Music]
i'm not sure i have much more to add on
that
our decisions are extremely determined
by our environment but being extremely
determined it's not the same as being
fully determined
exactly exactly they there is room for
for some decisions there are clearly
some decisions
uh where we spend a lot of time thinking
about we really wait we discuss with
ourselves maybe also with our friends
and relatives
and they are clear also our discussions
decisions sorry that we don't really
care much
and
that much easier and where we can uh
yeah
accept that we get uh
seriously influenced by the outside
world
professor thank you so much for spending
some of your time with me i appreciate
it i know it's late where you are
no it's okay it's 20 past
20
20 past eight so no that's perfect so
thank you very much for
for your time and uh
yeah tell me when that will be online
very good thank you thank you for your
interest in uh
in physics in science in free will and
in my
poor understanding of all those
thank you sir
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you